meriem vous avez suivi de près ce procès
qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir de ces
dernières semaines d'audition oui
bonjour plusieurs thématiques ont été
abordées dans l'est durant les derniers
deux dernières semaines de procès parmi
lesquels on peut en retenir 3
principalement d'abord l'état de santé
de julian assange ont longuement était
détaillé ensuite les conditions de sa
détention s'il venait à être extradé aux
états unis ont été également évoquées
pour savoir comment elle pourrait être
compatible avec son état de santé
psychologique on vient de le dire
et enfin la relation entre ce procès qui
se tient à londres pour les traditions
de du lan assange est un autre procès
qui se déroule actuellement en espagne
contre la société de surveillance us et
globales notamment par rapport à son
état de santé à julian assange qu'en est
il exactement
alors il a eu principalement de deux
témoignages ceux de deux psychiatres qui
ont longuement ausculté julian assange
qui ont étudié son cas et ils sont
formels le journaliste souffre d'une
forme d'autisme plus particulièrement du
syndrome d'asperger sa détention
prolongée et la perspective de
l'extradition leur font craindre je cite
un risque élevé de suicides l'un des
deux psychiatres même déclaré expliqué
que tulasne assange serait d serait déjà
en train de préparer
ce suicide en fait en rédigeant en et en
rédige et déjà des lettres d'adieu à sa
famille ainsi qu'un testament et qu'est
ce qu'on a appris sur les conditions de
détention de l'australien s'il devait
être extradé vers les états unis
alors de nombreux témoins
t'as testé que s'il était extradé aux
états unis il serait incarcéré sous un
régime très strict qui ne lui
permettrait pas d'avoir accès à d'autres
détenus ni même un suivi psychiatrique
tels que son état de santé le nécessite
il pourrait pas non plus avoir un accès
régulier à ses avocats ni même de
visites de ses proches il pourrait y en
avoir quelques unes mais il pourrait
même pas les toucher n'est ni même
toucher ses enfants et à propos du
procès que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
en espagne contre la société us et
globales en quoi ce procès impact
l'extradition qui est le prochain
d'extradition qui se tient à londres
alors oui ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que us et globales est une société
espagnole de surveillance elle avait été
embauchée par le gouvernement équatorien
pour surveiller l'ambassade quand julian
assange il était confiné vous savez
qu'il y a passé sept ans de 2012 à 2019
et cette société a dépassé donc c'est
aurait dépassé ses prérogatives en
espionnant au profit des autorités
américaines les moindres faits et gestes
de julian assange à l'intérieur de
l'ambassade d'équateur les moindres de
ses conversations les plus intimes et
les plus confidentielles aurait été
activement espionner filmé et transmises
aux autorités américaines
c'est là que se trouve le lien avec le
procès qui se déroule actuellement à
londres en fait parce que si les états
unis l'accusation américaine a pu avoir
accès aux conversations de julian
assange avec ses avocats
alors elle savait par avance la
stratégie de défense de julian assange
et le procès qui se déroule actuellement
à londres serait donc selon elle
caduc il se trouve aussi que un témoin
est venu
est venu raconter un témoin donc un
ancien employé de la société us et
globales qui est venu témoigner
anonymement
il a raconté que la société us et
globales en lien direct avec avec
washington aurait imaginé en 2010 est la
possibilité de kidnapper et
d'empoisonner comme vous l'avez dit
assange à l'ambassade d'équateur ce
témoignage fait écho à celui quelques
jours auparavant de cassandra fairbanks
qui est une journaliste américaine qui a
certifié que l'arrestation d'assange
vous savez en avril 2019 avait été
coordonnée sur ordre direct du président
américain donald trump une accusation
également donc porter preuve à l'appui
par la défense de julian assange
merci mérienne laribi pour ce décryptage
rappelle que vous avez suivi ce procès
pour le site web d'air tesfran certes et
france point tv